I'm joined now by Bryan Caplan editor at
the leading financial affairs
publication the bank at Bryan thank you
for joining us tonight and there is that
question isn't there I mean is this the
end of the coop Bank I think it's very
sad because clearly the cop did have a
great brand and you know it was known
for ethical banking in you know an
industry that struggled with
reputational issues so I think it's a
great shame it's probably gonna lose its
name now whatever happened so well so
there won't be a co-op bank there work
with co-op site but I don't think it's
its right to say that ethical banking is
completely dead because I think what's
happened is since the financial crisis
you know other banks have embraced at
least the ethical idea they're aware now
of what consumers want from them and
there are a lot of actual ethical funds
out there you can invest in now which
invest in in green projects or
sustainable development projects so I
mean I think the ideas will continue but
the name is going to go and it is
interesting isn't it because when there
were all those troubles a few years ago
2013 about all that money that they
needed to raise one of the things that I
think particularly the co-operative
group was keen to do was to ensure that
the name would live on on the high
street and that the values would stay
there as well so if this this is a kind
of gradual end of that error as it yeah
I mean I think the big blow really for
all of us as consumers and the
government was that what the government
really wants is to see a more
competitive banking sector and that
means having challenger banks and the
court was one of those now we may see it
merge with someone like the TSB and that
would create you know one of the bigger
smaller banks because what you want is
to get some competition for those big
four high street banks and make things a
bit more competitive out there but
specifically at the moment I mean we
know that the the coop has kind of had
struggled let's say over the course of
the last few years I mean there are some
takeovers there are some sales which are
kind of good news stories and there are
some which are bad news stories where
would you categorize this one yeah this
is a bad news story I mean you know it
got itself into so much trouble lost so
much money had to be rescued by hedge
funds I mean you know think about it you
know at a cooperative bank being rich
but rescued by American hedge funds and
then at the very least you would have
hoped it was going to find you know a
home somewhere and it wouldn't have to
do a forced sale which is what it's
doing now because it's losing this is
literally a forced sell if a financial
reason that's right because it was told
the regulator to keep a certain amount
of capital there it's falling below that
that target so it's really got to move
on and find somebody to give us some
financial support if customer's been
abandoning the bank thus far I mean
there are all these tails aren't there
that despite problems that banks have
people still stick with their bank that
they have their current account out
that's right I think you know customers
are very loyal especially to a brand
like the coop and you say there's lots
of interviews with people saying now I'm
still going to stay there there banks
will their accounts will find a home
somewhere but I think they will lose
that name you know perhaps it'll be
under TSP or virgin or one of the other
challenger banks and so that kind of
oligopoly that a lot of people have
talked about in the British banking
system you know those big banks
dominating the sector I mean that that's
living on for some time as it that's
living on and I think one of the sort of
lessons for us in the UK is that in the
rest of Europe you know they have made
cooperative banking work so in France
and Germany you have very strong
cooperative banking movements with
strong management and and well you know
financially well regulated our co-op
banks seem to lose its way it became a
bit of a political football it had a lot
of people running it who didn't really
have banking skills so that's the lesson
for us you know we should look to the
European model and copied that not not
gone with this one
okay Brian captain editor of the bank
thank you very much for joining us